morning good morning good morning
welcome to
the judiciary committee's orientation
meeting
for the 2021 session of the new
hampshire house of representatives
my name is ned gordon and as chair of
the house judiciary committee
in order to hold this remote meeting i
am required to read the following
statement i find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor
as a result of the covet 19 pandemic
and in accordance with the governor's
emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a committee orientation meeting
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by
zoom platform or by telephone all
necessary access information
has been made available in the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar
on the general court website the notice
for this meeting complies with house
rules
and with rsa 91-a
right to no law anyone who has a problem
accessing the meeting should call 271
3600 or email
hcs leg dot state
dot nh dot us
in the event that the public is unable
to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned
and rescheduled first
let me introduce the staff member who is
on the meeting assisting us that's
jennifer four
our committee researcher well jen
and uh please note that all votes that
are taken during this meeting if any
and we'll start the meeting by we're
required to start the meeting by taking
a roll call
attendance when each member states their
presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you
during the meeting which is required
again
under the right to know
again i am ned gordon i am at the dow
cottage
in bristol new hampshire and
susan duncan is in the house and may be
in the room at the same time
and my dog fergus is with me
and is mike sylvia on the
he shows up and there he is he is you
have audio
yep i am here in belmont
at home alone
and kurt walper is with us
attempting to take notes in his house in
stratford new hampshire
alone at the moment but my wife could be
by any time
hi mr chair i'm uh here in goffstown new
and kimberly rice thank you mr chairman
i am here
i am at the state house in concord
currently alone but
the deputy speaker may come in at any
time
dorne silver i'm here in my office
in guilford in my home office i'm alone
except for
bob green bob green is here at holmen
hudson
here with my wife just return from her
walk
diane is not with us
douglas trottier representative trottier
called looking for a fresh link
i don't know if that can get sent out to
him but he was unable to get in
okay he's just on the meeting with us
it looks like he's reconnecting right
now yeah
are you can you can you hear us doug
good morning representative trottier is
here
hi is anyone there with you
doug where where are you located i'm
district six in belmont
at your home at home yeah sorry that's
okay
thank you and margie smith
um marjorie smith i'm in durham where
else would i be
thank you is anyone with you no
and timothy bargain um i'm
i'm tim horrigan i'm also at i'm also in
durham i'd get out a little bit more
than marjorie but not that much but i'm
at my home in durham by myself
and charlotte lorenzo good morning
i am here in my home office in new
market with me
myself and i my husband may come
floating in
later on thank you
and wendy chase hi representative chase
i'm here in rollinsford in my home
by myself and cam
kenny thank you mr chairman um
i am here in my apartment in durham um
my roommates are probably in the
apartment but i am alone in my room
diane langley good morning mr chair i'm
here in my home in manchester
and my husband may be in and out thank
you
rebecca mcbee good morning thank you mr
chairman it's
becky macbeth i'm here in portsmouth in
my home office
and um i'm home alone but i have my cats
ferguson fiona with me
so well i had my dog fergus with me
i noticed that i wasn't gonna mention
that until i heard your name and i
i got mark page i'm in exeter with uh in
my home office but with family
around thank you mr chairman thank you
i'm here in exeter at my home and i'm
currently alone
but my sons and husband may walk through
between classes okay
thank you everybody so
uh wait um did you did you call paul
burch i don't remember
no how was saving the best for last
how could i overlook bob oh no
i am alone i am in west milan and
i am here and i am pleased to see
that uh kimberly kimberly rice is
looking well
and i i'm here as well mr chair uh mark
mclean
in a conference room by myself in the
as you can tell the committee is
composed of 19 members 10 of which will
be
republican and 9 democratic which i
guess is in proportion to the number
of seats in the full house
and as i indicated earlier i've been
appointed as chairman
but mark mclean is serving as our vice
chair
and uh kurt wolper has graciously agreed
to serve as our clerk again
[Music]
we did a fine job last year and
uh representative smith who was our
chair last year will be the ranking
minority member and with her deputy her
second command being
charlotte representative d lorenzo
i can only hope that i could do half a
good a job as uh
as representative smith did last year
last turn
you're here it's kind of you to say ned
but i
assume you're going to do twice as good
a job
well i will i will do my i'll do my best
to uh that's what i mean i rest my case
so i i guess the maybe the best way to
start is and i think this is the way we
started
two years ago with you representative
smith and that was just
having everybody go around and do a
brief introduction
particularly for the benefit of any new
members
just to tell us a bit about yourself
excuse me so uh
and and i'll start and i'll try not to
the uh my name is ned gordon i'm a
retired
uh a semi-retired attorney i still
practice law
a little bit but mostly pro bono cases
helping people
and i'm right as i said a retired judge
i do
sit on the retirement board the judicial
retirement board i've been chairing the
ethics committee although i don't know
whether i'll be reappointed
and
[Music]
that's it for the most part
um mark mclean um i'm neither a lawyer
nor retired judge but
uh i'm an engineer and i'm excited to be
a part of this committee again and the
wait who me
oh i thought you'd go through i i
figured i'd be the end of the list
ned thank you very much my name is
marjorie smith
um i've been in the legislature
with the exception of one term when
voluntarily took a sabbatical and then
realized i missed you all and i came
back
and when people ask me why um
i'm still there i say i'm going to stay
until
we get it right and we haven't gotten it
right yet um
i am not an attorney my professional
training
is in public administration um
and my legislative service has been uh
on either fine finance or judiciary
having chaired each of those committees
for two terms um
and uh i'm looking forward
to working with everybody in the same
way
that this committee has which is
surprisingly nonpartisan
on overwhelmingly on the issues that
come before us
and um it's why i was
thrilled that not only was
mark named as vice chair but that he's
back again because one of mark's
favorite bills where he
took the leadership and did an
incredible amount of work is
on our very interesting list of bills
and he knows which one i mean
good morning everyone my name is
charlotte lorenzo and
i'm going into my third term as a state
rep
i served on the judiciary committee for
the previous two terms
my my i guess my
expertise is in housing housing
management
landlord tenant law not that i'm a
lawyer or look like one or play one on
tv
but um i did manage housing in maine new
hampshire
and massachusetts uh for over 35 years
got to work with um federal laws state
laws
local laws um and the whole gamut
so thank you and i'm very happy to be
here
representative rice while you're still
with us
thank you mr chairman so i'm
representative tim rice
i am um entering my fourth term
i am the chair of children and family
law
and the speaker pro tem and
so bear with me i'll be a little busy
but i'm really excited
to to really learn a lot i learned a lot
about children and family law on that
committee so
i'm very eager for this work thanks so
much and again i apologize that i have
to run
but uh welcome everyone and have a great
day
and representative wolfer uh
so let's see what i want to say i mean
starting my fourth term
in the house um i spent uh
34 years working at the navy yard in
portsmouth
dealing extensively with technical
documentation interpretation
of various regulations which was good
what i want to call it training for
being here in the house
i on the judiciary committee i always
have been
because i wanted to work on life issues
so
i'm chairman of the pro-life caucus and
a pro-life advocate
and with that uh i guess that's enough
for now we'll know the rest
as we go along representative birch
won't forget you this time thank you mr
chair
uh as as you know i'm paul burch this is
my
fifth term all of which i've spent on
judiciary
i'm a uh retired uh public defender when
i retired in vermont i was vermont
senior public defender
which basically means i've been told no
by more judges than anyone else in the
history of the state of
vermont and um i tend to
pay a little extra attention to issues
of
police accountability relationship of
citizens to their governor
to their government and rights of
juveniles
and representative alexander
hi everyone thank you mr chair my name
is joe alexander i'm serving my second
term
um i represent goffstown um sorry
there's a blunder going off in
background
um i recently just got my masters in
public policy and i have
specifically a passion for housing
policies so
representative horrigan hello i'm tim
horrigan i've
just started my my seventh term so i'm
just starting to learn how this place
works so i've been on
this is my fifth term on judiciary um
before that
um i was on a something called the
petitions and redress committee which
speaker bill o'brien
tried for a year and it was not a
terribly successful experiment but it
was kind of funny and i was also on a
election law for a term and um
ironically before i was state rep one of
the things i was working on as a private
citizen was like
legacy rep my father served in the late
1970s and early 1980s and i
and when we're back in the state house i
often seems like my name tag
looked a little bit older than the
others so i've often
wondered if maybe they put his in the
they put his in the storage room and
then pulled it out again when another
rep with the same name
came along but i don't know that for
sure but
so that that's basically that's
basically who i am and you'll
i guess you'll get to know me uh more
representative sylvia
um i'm uh mike sylvia i
live in belmont um coming into my
fifth term here all on judiciary um
i retired from fedex after 34 years
so now when i'm not participating i'm uh
out running
and uh occasionally uh up mount
washington
hi everyone i'm wendy chase i am in my
second year
or second term of being a representative
and this is my second term serving on
judiciary
i am a small business owner and a mom
other than that i don't have any
other type of political training but i
absolutely love what i do and i'm really
excited about being back
on the judiciary committee i enjoyed
so much last year i loved mark that
i don't love that our bill is back but i
love that we'll be able to work on that
again
and um ned i'm really looking forward to
your leadership and learning
a lot more about how the judiciary
committee works thank you and
i guess the chairman this i'm bob green
i represent hudson and pelham
i'm beginning my second term in the
house last term i was on legislative
administration and i did a brief stint
on finance
and uh so i'm i'm excited to be here
uh i'm just judiciary i'm also serving
as vice chair of richie admin this time
around i'm excited about that too
and i my background is i'm a 20-year air
force veteran
i retired in 0.7 and i worked doing web
and graphic
communications for a bunch of different
companies most recently
from bae systems in hudson and i retired
out of there
about 15 months ago glad to be here
thank you
hi i'm diane langley i'm representing
manchester
ward one this is my second term in the
house
and it will be my second term on
judiciary i'm thrilled to be back on
that committee i
am i learned a lot last time and i think
my learning curve is
is continuing my background
professionally
is i'm a nursing administrator and i
have spent 25 years in my career
in primarily in mental health and the
next 15 in
adult and elderly services and
developmental services
human services so i'm very interested i
like
the variety of the bills that that we
have in
or that we have had on judiciary because
i think they really affect people's
lives
yes i'm norm silver belknap district 2
which is guilford and meredith
this is my second term although not
consecutively i was in
the house in 17 and 18 on the election
law committee
took a two-year break voluntarily
because i thought i was going to have to
leave the state
and then i decided to come back and so
i'm back and now i'm on judiciary
i am a semi-retired lawyer i'm licensed
in new hampshire as well as in florida
i practiced law in miami for 40 years
before i was managed i managed to escape
and come to new hampshire i've tried
cases in state and federal court i've
done lots of transactional work
uh a variety of things but now i do a
very limited practice
and uh i'm active in a lot of uh
political advocacy groups i'm a second
amendment supporter
i've been very active in the republican
national lawyers association
working in ballot integrity issues and
things of that sort
and it's going to be an interesting
transition from
election law into judiciary glad to be
here
thank you uh mr chairman i'm km kenny
this is my second term
uh both terms assigned to judiciary i
graduated from the university of new
hampshire
in 2018 i decided to settle here in
durham right after graduation and ran
for
representative and now i represent
durham and madbury along with
representative smith
and horrigan and um i'm excited to work
with each and every one of you thank you
you graduated from unh 48 years after i
did
yeah representative trottier
good morning thank you mr chair my name
is douglas trottier
i live in belmont i represent um
district six this is my first term
i'm retired law enforcement currently
working part-time at the region
community college in their campus safety
department
i've been a business owner um i look
forward to
learning and moving forward with this
committee
forgive me oh no problem i'm used to it
um
so i'm becky macfast i'm from portsmouth
i've lived here 30 years
um this is my fourth term in the
legislature and this is the first time i
wrote down a preference always before it
said put me where you need me and i've
been on commerce for
three terms and i'm really excited to
learn these issues and work hard with
you all
and and collaborate on what's before us
um
i um i am an attorney um i practice
primarily in the probate court and
litigation
some estate planning and family court
i'm a guardian ad litem
and um in all the circuit courts mostly
in the probate court but i do do some
family work
um i have four adult children that live
in new hampshire
i don't know that they always will but
i'm holding my breath
and um i'm originally from kentucky
but lived outside of dc for most of my
years and then went back and worked
after college on capitol hill for
um a member of congress from virginia
and the governor from virginia
and i came to new hampshire in the late
80s on a presidential
campaign and i never left so that's my
story
i really look forward to working with
you all and thank you very much for
thank you mr chair i'm alexis simpson i
live in exeter
um but i represent the floaterial
district of exeter newmarket new fields
and stratum
i'm a minister in the united church of
christ professionally
and i was in the state house a few terms
ago with many of you so it's good to see
you again
um at that point i was on the
environment and agriculture committee
so i'm really looking forward to the
work here i
did um in between time i did a masters
in ethics and public policy
so that's a real passion of mine as well
and i'm a mom of two teenage boys
and have any
as representative kelly taught or paige
joined us
i'm here diane kelly hi welcome
hi thank you i missed quite a bit and i
am totally frazzled from completely
unusual and unexpected tech
issues so i barely remember my own name
right now but um
i represent district 25 hillsborough 25.
i moved to temple i'm from temple new
hampshire and i moved here
a little over two years ago from
southern california to escape the
people's republic
and um i'm super happy to be here and
um just love new hampshire and and
i have three adult children who moved
here before i did and
um i'm a real estate agent um
uh just yeah just looking forward to
welcome thanks
[Music]
uh it's a uh i think it'll be a great
committee and
a good committee to uh to work with and
to accomplish things i think that's
uh certainly my focus or my objective
and
that's i'm frankly not very partisan
my focus is on getting things done and i
hope it appears to me that this is the
type of committee that will do that
but you do have 47 bills that have been
signed
assigned to the committee so far
chairman excuse me mr chairman yeah i
i just wanted to introduce myself i've
been on the call this is
mark page i'm sorry that's okay i just
thought i'd uh
jump in and if we're done with
introductions i'll do mine i guess
yeah i'm mark page i'm from exeter this
is my first term in the legislature
i am a recovering attorney i did
represent school districts in the state
for a number of years and now i teach
public policy
and uh three kids and again live in
exeter i'm looking forward to working
with the committee so
thanks very much mr chairman where do
you
where do you teach representative page i
teach at umass
university massachusetts right
thank you thank you welcome mr chair
yeah excuse me i'm sorry i didn't say i
don't believe where
i am from i'm from rollinsford and i
represent
stratford county district 18 which is
somersworth in rollinsford
and my family has been traced back to
living in new hampshire since the late
1700s so i'm a true native
a true native i just wanted to say where
i was
who i represented thank you no you're
you're
you're welcome the uh
we do have 47 bills that have been
and uh i think lots of the questions
that would ordinarily be addressed at an
orientation meeting we're not going to
and we do anticipate that there will be
long
hearings and that's one thing that you
a couple of things one is uh
they hope to outfit the
legislative office building so that we
can hold hearings there
in double wide rooms to open up the
rooms to have double rooms
and to allow people to attend in person
but i think it's also their plan for
both
at this point in time for both hearings
on bills and also for executive sessions
to allow
and so if you are feeling uncomfortable
about
actually attending hearings that you may
be able to participate
remotely
the i know there's been a question as to
whether or not mass would be required i
certainly
would prefer that people wear masks
particularly given
my own health concerns and would
encourage
wearing masks if in fact people are
going to participate in the hearing
although i'm not sure that they can be
we certainly the rooms will be set up so
that we can socially distance
and i understand that there are air
treatment systems that have been ordered
and were supposed to be delivered this
week for the rooms so
to make to address
those particular issues with regard to
they're looking as they're looking
for long hearing so they're there
they feel that they only would be able
to run
four hearings perhaps at a time at most
five hearings at a time
in the legislative office building
and given the number of committees that
means
that in order to make that work
there needs to be two things happen one
is we probably will have to have
committee meetings five days a week
uh or aveda that the committee hearing
rooms will be available five days a week
so there maybe have to be committee
hearings on fridays
and mondays and not just the tuesdays
wednesdays and thursdays
that we've been accustomed to and
and if we do have hearings that may be
full day hearing days
and as i indicated earlier before we
started
you know he with 47 bills that means
that we'd
at least have to have five full days
it's anticipated that testimony will be
given
remotely that people will not be
appearing to testify
for the committees all testimony will be
remote
at this point in time with regard to
what
traditionally are known as the blue
sheets and the pink cards
i don't believe unless it was decided
yesterday that the house has actually
come to terms as to how those will be
done
i did testify in a senate hearing
yesterday and
they did have online what is the
equivalent of the pink card
or the blue sheet and
you were able to use that well it seems
that
that system ought to be able to be used
or
to accommodate the house as well but as
yet
i'm not sure that those things have been
figured out nor have they figured out
how testimony will be submitted
with regard to the bills themselves what
i would certainly plan to do you know
there are different types
just as has been done in the past i'm
sure that we can clump
bills together to be heard that have a
common theme
we have the right to know bills for
example and
bills that have to do with court
administration
some bills that have to do just with
legal process or
landlord tenant or personal privacy or
reproductive rights or restrictions and
so
what i do is i'll try to lump them all
together so that they can be heard at
some bills may not require
immediate action and the question is
on those types of bills should we retain
them do we need to actually act on all
of those bills this session would it be
better to retain
some of the bills and then think about
working on them
when the world is a little bit different
and
perhaps we would have more time to
address the bills
rather than to rush through
that's a great idea i like that idea but
i don't think a lot of people in the
room understand what
you mean when you say that we should
retain them and work on them when we
have more time
well by retaining
my intent would be to uh
and i don't know what the official
language is in the first session whether
it's retained
i think it's retained but retain the
bill
the idea is that it would then be worked
on in the
generally in the fall or sometime
after but generally in this particular
case in the fall
and then come back before the
legislature in the second year
of the session
and by the beginning of
next session it may be that enough
people have been
vaccinated or we have
or we will have more ability to get
together and
work on things than we do currently
knowing that margery is isolated and
[Laughter]
durham
gordon at a good time representative
smith and horrigan um have questions
yeah and representative smith
um thank you very much mr chair um
i am conscious kurt
raised one issue that i want to raise i
am conscious that we have a few freshmen
and i'm not sure the reference to pink
cards and blue sheets translates
into normal english communication
so could you kind of explore that whole
bit about
how we hear from people
either as testimony or in terms of their
just being able to voice their opinion
right the pink cards typically are cards
which you
submit generally when you are going to
testify and testify in favor
or an opposition or just to provide
information on
on a bill and submit it to
the committee on the committee chair
typically
to be called on to participate so
basically it triggers your act of
particip
basically a pink card triggers your
active participation in the committee
process
as generally a member of the public
or a lobbyist who intends to speak on a
particular bill
the blue sheets themselves generally
indicate uh your support
or or against a bill
and so that you can register your
support for a particular
bill one way or the other
and is that an adequate explanation
representative smith
well i guess we have to ask the freshmen
who are on the committee
as to whether it's adequate i mean do
they think we're speaking a foreign
language
or can they figure it out that's my
question
i would encourage the new members to ask
any questions that they might have
good idea thank you with regard to the
process
the uh and also it's pretty typical for
people to submit written testimony and
there needs to be a mechanism for the
submission of that
right now that leads into
that leads into my main question which
was um actually we had
i think this committee just had an
executive session but several committees
did
actually have hearings especially all
the finance
bills that finance was going to hear
like in the last half of march
adhering so there is a procedure they
cobbled together and it actually worked
pretty well
effect i'm gonna say it probably worked
better
than how we did it before because you
would email basically you would uh
submit it you know up to uh up to up to
the staff from the fourth floor and then
they would uh
then they would you know then and send
it on to the committee so i think that
worked better in the old procedure where
you
pass the papers around the table because
you know sometimes people don't bring
enough
we had one freaking visitor who would
drink one copy and then
complain about how expensive
photocopying was although she eventually
started emailing us our stuff
and it wasn't a procedure for dealing
with incoming emails i think actually
there is a procedure i think maybe it's
better than what we had in the past so i
would
just uh so i would certainly urge you in
the
other chairs to take a close look at
that aspect of it
and um that was the main thing i was
asked about like what the procedure was
and
whether we'd be building on what we did
do successfully
in this summer and also
with the retain bills do they have to
wait till 2022 to come to the floor or
would there be any
or would be able to bend the rules
enough so we could have possibly
obsession days in the fall of 2021 and
get some of them out of the way or would
they
all have to wait till after we convene
in
well typically the committee would meet
to consider
the retain bill perhaps later in the
year but typically it wouldn't come back
before the legislature until the
beginning of the next year but i don't
know whether
there potentially might be some rule
change which would allow that
which which leads to the whole list
of sort of unanswered questions
right now if you ask ask me
uh what room we're going to meet in i
can't answer that question so typically
at our orientation we'd be deciding that
we're going to meet in a particular room
generally 208 in the legislative office
building
it could be that we won't have one room
assigned but we'll be
assigned a particular double room it
could be any double room
which gets to another issue and
typically what would happen is
i think it's up to the chair of the
committee to
select the seating arrangement well
unless you know
where your how your committee is going
to be laid out you can really can't do a
seating arrangement either which i would
intend to do
the hearings were supposed to have begun
next week and we
to hold our first hearing next week and
we're getting a little late for that
because we'd have to meet the calendar i
think today
in order to have a hearing next week and
of course we have the holiday next week
but i think things have been exacerbated
by
the security issues next week as well so
i'm not sure what the
status of hearings next week so
typically we would have expected one
next week i don't know that that's going
to happen
[Music]
thing that i certainly would encourage
everybody to do as well
and that is obviously i'm going to
expect
because you've signed up to do this duty
that you're going to attend
the committee meetings but if you can't
for some reason
you should let your office know that
you're not going to be able to attend
and perhaps a substitute could be
provided in your place
so that we'll have be able to keep our
balance
with regard to fair balance with regard
the committee reports in terms of the
process and the procedure
marjorie did such an excellent job
certainly i would
plan to continue to be to
handle the committee in the same manner
as we have in the past with the same
rules that we have in the past and i
know that doesn't mean much to perhaps
new members
but i'm sure that they will
learn very quickly that we do
manage to have a particular decorum
that we don't keep food in the room
that we act respectfully towards
everyone who testifies
and if you're testifying on your own
bill
that you won't participate in the
discussion when you're
a committee member uh
as i said the testimonies intended to be
remote on all bills
but it may be that you have a bill which
is in place
and you happen to be in the building at
the same time if that's the case
i understand that they will let you
testify in person if you're a sponsor of
the bill
and that's you know other than questions
i think that's what i
intend just to communicate to you today
and that is uh
well for whatever reason i was selected
to be your chair the one thing that i
will focus on is being fair
and being efficient and trying to get as
much accomplished as we can
[Music]
and being respectful of everybody on the
committee and everybody who appears
before
are there other concerns or questions
i typically what would happen we do have
the types of bills in the past where
we've been required to be
i don't know that that's going to be
necessary this year if
all of our testimony is going to be
received
electronically because i don't know that
there would be a need for us to be
in representatives but
if there were we certainly would make
those earnings if there was a need we
representative representatives maclean
and
uh burch have questions oh we're
supposed to put our hands up
thank you mr chair um one of the things
that the staff was talking about was
having us
identify some technical resources maybe
for some training to assist
um you know obviously kurt is going to
be having
the the clerking role but um was there
any thought to canvas to members uh to
see if anybody has any interest in that
area
in in what what type of technical
issues just you know helping to
coordinate
the zoom meetings while you're involved
are are there are there any particular
concerns with regard to technical issues
at this point perhaps any of the new
members
um if i can if i can interject um
i think a representative mclean is is
referencing the possibility of having
a member of the committee who can take
on the role that
i would have or i have been having since
we started this zoom process
um where in public hearings you may need
to
promote an attendee to the panelist side
keep an eye on the screen to make sure
that anyone who has
questions that that's brought to the
attention of the chair
things like that so we're we're thinking
of
identifying folks on the committee who
can assist
in that respect um to take
some of those responsibilities off the
shoulder of the chair
um and also recognizing that with um
just four researchers right now
it'll be hard for us to be everywhere
and covering that
role throughout with the the 20
committees that we have
mr chair if they're i would be happy
it's
it's margie speaking i would be happy to
um volunteer to um
be your um sherpa
if um if that
is uh would be helpful to you and
perhaps we
should have two people so that we're
sure there's always one there
to help worry about the details so that
you can focus
on the more important issues
well i was expecting that representative
mclean would
be assisting with the technical issues
as well
good choice mr chair yeah i
i i absolutely uh intend to be doing
that as well
it's great to have representative smith
there as well so that we can tag team
with each other
and in case one of us is not there
somebody else can
seamlessly slip back into that role and
also of course when representative
mclean is
okay and we know which bill it will be
so exactly the work's all done mark
that's going to be the easiest job
you're going to have
and representative burch did you have a
question i
did and thank you mr chair you made
reference to the generally uh
the general practice of uh
sponsors of bills not taking part in the
uh questioning at the hearings
of other witnesses and the like i'm
wondering if that is going to apply
to co-sponsors because i heard there was
some discussion
about what role co-sponsors of bills
i don't know the answer to that i don't
know if anyone
ned i'm about elaborating on what
paul just said of course this prime
sponsor presents the bill
and speaks and whatever in the past what
we've done
is you choose you either decide that you
are going to testify
in which case at for that hearing your
role
is as is not as a committee member but
as someone who testifies
or you choose not to testify
and you can sit at
the you know the committee table but
you don't ask questions if you are a
co-sponsor
i mean but i don't know what the the
current speaker
uh will have to say about whether
i mean have been a lot of changes
apparently and
and how we're going to act some base
because of the realities of the pandemic
and some for other reasons
so i guess that would have to be
clarified
yeah i think that's was my response to
paul is
you know i know what the practice has
been i but i don't know if there has
been a change in that practice
thank you um
if i'll jump in and probably and other
people
oh go ahead represent morgan
oh thank you mr chair sorry i i'm
moving so you guess i've we had several
other uh
hearings yesterday where other chairs
said we'd have the hybrid meetings which
uh
is i'm happy with my
we're a little bit unsure whether
members you participate remotely
and right now i'm one of those who was
really
quite reluctant to go anywhere near the
state house between the cohen
issues and the civil unrest issues and
i'm not a particularly fearful person
well the
hybrid the members who are visually
remotely have
all the same privileges and powers as
those who were meeting in person
because there's been some rumors going
around that like
people members are meeting who are you
know me
zooming in to a meeting that a summit
person attendees won't be able to ask
questions we won't be able to do other
things which uh
normally we take it for granted that all
committee members can do
the second question is is the five
committee meetings
is that just a budgetary thing because
we don't
want to pay for more than five uh zoom
licenses or whatever other
licenses or is that um also because it's
just the physical limitations on the
size of the lob that
if we have only double wide rooms
there's only so many double wide rooms
we can have at one time
so no i i i can answer the second
question
easily because i know the answer to that
and that is it's just
a physical limitation on that building
so
um with regard to the
first part the first question
i don't um the
the uh i guess i'm assuming
that if you participate remotely you'll
have the same
abilities that you would if you were
there as a committee member in person or
should
but i obviously i can't guarantee that
because i don't know exactly
technically whether or not that that i
know that there were
there were discussions early on about
limitations in the executive session
uh with regard to participation
uh but i do i'm not sure that those
thank you mr chair and of course with
the executive sessions we had many
executive sessions this summer and um
totally remotely so we know it's
technically possible we'll do a remote
executive session
and anyway thank you mr chairman yeah
there any other
you want to talk about the dress code
just because we don't have one
well you know that's it's kind of
interesting because i was thinking about
the meeting today and of course i put on
a jacket and a tie
oh my goodness i didn't put my jacket on
i'm sorry yeah well
geez i don't know what we're going to do
and but i've been in so many i've been
in so many zoo
meetings uh recently where
it's just in
it's informal so people tend not to
dress up
personally you know i think my
expectation is that you would
dress in a manner which you dress if you
had a hearing at the state house but
[Music]
i think that that would be appropriate
because the public is going to be
viewing you
and forming their impression of you
and the legislature as a whole so
i think my expectation would be that you
mr chairman if i may um i was just
following uh representative burch's lead
with no tie so i'll have a tie on it
next hearing though
and and mr chairman i i will not have a
tie
no i'm gonna have a jacket
yeah appropriate attire
mr chairman i have a question if i can
just for clarification
so that the hearings are going to be
held in a double-wide
room in person yet testimony
or people that are testifying are going
to do that via zoom is that correct
that's correct yes
that's my understanding and uh
and if you're my understanding at this
point in time if you're a committee
member you can participate
via zoom right okay
and one of the issues is
the types of hearings that we've had in
judiciary
are you going to have a hallway full of
people
at the state house it makes no sense to
bring in
a ton of people and have people exposed
so i think if through testimony
everybody
testifies over zoom that makes
a lot more sense
as i testified in the hearing yesterday
it went very smoothly the senate
had for the so-called pink cards
they have this thing online which you
filled in
it actually was easier than do filling
out a pink card i think
it was terrific
and they collate them five minutes
before the hearing and
following it's terrific
so will this be a screen that we'll all
be able to see if we're there
in the hearing i'm just trying to
envision this and also so you had your
for instance you just testified and you
had your
pink card does it then come first
first come first serve as to who
testifies
by who fills out the card i think the
i think this the chair picks who
testifies and what order people testify
just as they do now
typically uh yesterday senators spoke
first i spoke
and that's an interesting question as to
and of course as a
testifying i could
zoom in and i could see all the
committee members
but i don't believe the committee
members are seeing the people who
testifies
oh and how did they ask questions
we should just wait
ned isn't the way it worked this spring
is so that
you know we have panelists and we have
attendees
and if and people who are watching
because for whatever reason
including that they're planning to
testify
when the chair calls that person um
at least in the spring what happened was
that
and summer that that person would then
temporarily be moved
into the panelist category would appear
on the screen
so that the committee could see that
witness
and that witness could see the committee
and
um uh and of course anybody who's what
else was watching could see the
committee and the witness
and then when the witness finished uh
the witness would go back to the
attendee category and
could continue to watch the the
committee
and hear the committee but just wouldn't
be on the screen
i i mean jennifer would know more but i
think that's
kind of uh i mean i imagine they're
going to
figure out the things that worked well
and that did
and keep those and then just try to
fine-tune the things that
the speaker and the chair is that
um the whole issue as to whether we
would move into
executive session on a bill
immediately after having her testimony
under um certain
uh leaders and and rules in the house
um there was an insistence that we did
not
execute bill at the same time
that we heard the testimony unless there
was a particular
overarching reason to do it um
and i have heard discussions generally
about
whether that would continue or whether
it might
make it easier um to move
from from the
committee hearing to the executive
session if in fact
the committee is ready to um
to exec you know in other words not
having a subcommittee formed or a work
session or whatever
and that i guess is that's going to be a
mr chair is going to be something that
you
and the speaker and others have
are going to have to work out right
well as of last friday we
would adhere to the policy that we had
last year and that is you would not exec
on the same day terrific
but whether whether that changes between
now and the time we have an executive
and and we will continue to have you
know because the calendar will come out
on thursday night
everybody's read that calendar thursday
night and
the earliest there could be a hearing
would be the next monday
yes
you have to have four days notice okay
thank you okay
if there are any then i want to thank
everybody for participating today i'm
really looking forward to the year
um it's a i think you know it was
i can't tell you how pleased i was with
the appointments to the committee it
just seems like it's a
terrific committee with lots of
qualified able
anyway i wish you all the best and well
and uh we'll uh and we'll get through it
one way or another
thank you mr chair thank you one way or
another
thank you mrs threw it one way or
another thank you
yeah anything i can do now yeah thank
you mr
chair and i i miss seeing you and susan
at section 105 at the web so but
see ya stay with that thank you thank
you